[Musique]
et
la famille gergès les chants de noël
sont en arabe
nous sommes dans une famille irakienne
des chrétiens d'orient réfugiés à blois
bonjour je m'appelle thomas je suis
inquiet j'ai 14 ans je m'appelle 16 j'ai
douze au trésor et je suis et racker
même modestement même en exil fêter noël
est un immense moment de joie après les
noëls cachés dans le fief de dèche à
mossoul
en france toutes les facilités mais on
n'ira que pas du tout il n'y avait rien
on pouvait pas mettre de sapin on
pouvait pas faire deux repas on devait
tout cacher rien laisser paraître
on pouvait ni aller à l'église est
restée à la maison seulement aux ici on
ressent vraiment la fête de noël c'est
pas du tout comme en irak avec leur
arrivée en france ces chrétiens d'orient
trouve dans noël l'occasion de renouer
avec leurs traditions
même en l'absence de ceux qu'on aime ma
famille partir rac à ladoux 2007 à
l'ailé f syrie après la canéda ger ger
pas famille avec moi
un irak parfaite sa famille pas content
malgré l'exil malgré les absents c'est
un noël de fête pour cette famille de
chrétiens d'orient arrivé depuis un peu
plus d'un an maintenant en france ils
sont aujourd'hui à blois et pour eux le
simple fait de se rendre à la messe de
noël est une immense liberté une liberté
qu'ils ont chèrement payé